Jiji welcome to Campeche yeah thank you
for having me I haven't been to camp in
years but loves that did you go to camp
as a kid I did every single summer Oh a
veteran yeah I know I know it's like
more about the glamping rather than
camping so yeah I don't see GG camping
well maybe like a cute like Lodge some
big news at VidCon the documentary is
coming yes it honestly doesn't even feel
real the fact that people are asking me
about it it's like oh my god you know
about it I can tell will you we can talk
about it it's not a secret anymore right
it's been cuz you've been filming for so
long and you haven't nailed it
tell everyone what are you excited for
your fans to see when this finally comes
out I'm excited for so many reasons but
I'm more so nervous because it's a side
of me that I've never shown before it's
literally every aspect every facet
relationships family personal but the
most personal things that ever happened
in my life so I'm very very nervous but
I'm really hoping for the best what
number VidCon for you is this I think
it's my third or my fourth time ago a
third okay well we'll play it safe wait
yeah what it changes every year it gets
bigger every year 30,000 people this
year really yeah well I just got here so
I can't really I can't really speak to
that but I was in the elevator the
service elevator and I saw a bunch of
crazy big floats and stuff so I'm just
excited to go walk around what else can
we expect from Gigi in 2016 oh so many
things but obviously they're under wraps
just like the Darby was yes exactly
documentary is literally just I'm so
excited to finally talk about it it's
like all I can talk about so let's just
keep it one at a time here I love it
you'll be watching I'm sure we will see
you when it comes out thank you so much
for selling by Campeche candy juices you
want to take anything to go I'll take
this power go for it